well we have this story from timcast.com
nearly 70 percent of liberals say it's
more important to protect ukraine's
border than our own what i don't know if
it's seventy percent i think we get it
i thought it was 57. you have a link to
the poll on this one because it might be
okay but i think that okay that doesn't
surprise me and and i and i think um
yeah it's 57. reason doesn't surprise me
because there's there's a lot of people
that i know again i always make a
distinction between liberal and the left
but there's a lot of people on the left
and i know that
and any other country in the world is
better than our own like we are we are
uniquely evil in some capacity for which
we must pay you know you know
i don't know
we just need to be sorry all the time
and so the idea that you would ask them
should we protect our border ukraines of
course it would be ukraine's because the
only way we protect our border is if you
know we're all a bunch of racism it
defies jesus's logic did you do you
splank out of your own eye first did you
see that they're calling on cbp to leave
the southern border to go to poland to
process ukrainian refugees
it's remarkable i'm going to check that
out as things that things that don't
surprise me anymore yeah
things that don't surprise me anymore i
wow
so okay back to the story for a second
you said it's 57 58 percent 57 of
democrats so not the title was wrong but
we're going to copyright that i think
the title is okay so somewhere between
57 and 70 but you think it's more close
to 57
49 of them
well you got to log into uh tourist
music if you want to get the hard
numbers i the idea that we should send
our national guard overseas to fight is
completely insane that's completely
insane this is the national our custom
and border protection agents like border
patrol like our border patrol their job
is to run the border and they're like
go to
do
poland
think it's because they fired so many
people for not being vaccinated no that
actually sounds like they would allocate
resources like we are a border patrol
and there's a border issue in that crane
okay that's where the fish should be
right and by the way does ukraine have a
coast because we have a coast guard we
do yeah
yeah they got they got a coast and off
the black sea they have a government so
they could use our army yeah
you know governments need armies they
could have ourselves ships wow man
that's why i was saying the other day
i'm like i'm ready to put my feet up and
crack open a coconut no never never
never give up never surrender always
chance always change so much give up but
kind of like just glide you know oh
that's good like we're we've fallen off
the cliff just spread your wings and
enjoy i do think we need to make uh
entertainment for a while and veer away
from the negativity
and of war and conflict and
so i don't think those two interestingly
enough i don't think those two things
are mutually exclusive not an either or
a proposition in fact i'm willing to say
and again this is not one of those this
is not one of those you know george bush
we just got attacked so go shopping
right like i'm not saying that
um i i do i do think there's a realm for
like you know sacrifice when the times
call for it
but
like i as i look at like all the things
that are kind of under assault the way
things are acting
there there is a huge realm right now
one of the reasons why we are in the
situation we're on right now
is because we didn't fight for the
cultural space
um
we you know we might fight for the
political space we didn't fight for the
cultural space which is why it is
dominated by by a certain perspective or
viewpoint and i i tell parents this all
the time when they're well how are we
going to fix our schools or how are we
going to like well if you think you're
going to fix your schools with one
election cycle you're out of your mind
yeah because your child your child is
now going to a school which in many
cases is pushing a particular world view
or particular you know propaganda that
might not coincide with your own beliefs
about your country or faith or whatever
i said then they come home and they
watch the t they watch netflix right and
chances are whatever they're watching
there is going to be pushing a
particular worldview then they turn on a
song which is pushing a world view then
they look at the media which is personal
worldview and then they go to their
college professor which is personal
worldview and then what do you get 30
minutes around the dinner table you
think this is sufficient and so any any
sort of activity i see which is pushing
into that cultural space which is so
critical because everything political is
downstream from culture
is absolutely necessary and one of the
most important like fronts that we're in
right now but there's two good things to
say here some some optimism one is
you've got the daily wire
ramping up production of cultural uh
content they're buying movies
they're they're absolutely they
absolutely see your point and they're
working towards it but then i would say
that um when you say we haven't you know
gotten gotten involved in the culture or
i forgot exactly how you said it well
ian and i uh did not come into this as
conservatives yeah so there's a lot of
people who were working in some kind of
entertainment some kind of media or
cultural space and now find themselves
in agreement on many core issues of
freedom in the united states and our
constitution with conservatives and
that's giving a big cultural boon yes so
you know we we talked with the guy from
the daily wire about you know how we can
expand our cultural uh content we have a
vlog we do silly jokes and have fun and
we do flips and into bean bags and stuff
but we're talking about you know things
we can do we launched a show called
tales from the inverted world yeah which
is and we have a book
available at invertedworldbook.com
and it's mysteries mysteries ufos ghost
stories because um
you know we've always been involved in
that yeah we actually got a mix of a
song that uh that we've been putting
together so so we're putting out music
so we're gonna yeah it's fantastic stuff
goosebumps so like i grew up playing
music i grew up making skate videos i
grew up making you know videos with my
friends and now
what the what the left is kind of
screwed up is that
they're they're constantly pushing
people
they're making authoritarian demands of
people to give in to their politics and
their views or else and a lot of people
are saying or else and they're walking
away yeah yeah so now there's an
opportunity here for conservatives to
get back in the game yeah and push back
on the left and i think in the long run
the left will lose the culture the
culture i was in hollywood acting in
2006
kind of and i was like i'm going to
change the world i'm going to become a
famous actor and then be able to give
the speech at the oscars that changes
everyone yeah that was my idea but it
was so dirty that industry i felt so
sexualized and they were like just so
sexy sex sex and i'm like it's gotta be
right out of here man felt their fingers
coming at me and i just ran but but i
bailed on culture for like a decade i
started building minds the social
network you know that's
that's why people get involved in
politics is because we're not pretty
enough for hollywood and we're too
stupid for the private sector so yes
case in point but it's got to be done
it's got to be done
i didn't like that top-down uh pressure
in hollywood of like the the oligarchs
of hollywood that were these like weird
sexual deviants seemed like they were
kind of creating the the feel or the
energy of the system it was gross yeah
beautiful city though until recently i
guess because the homeless
incursion is terrifying but beautiful um
weather that's for sure because the
valley
the mountains and the it's like you got
snow capped peaks to the north an hour
you got the desert to the east in an
hour you got the ocean to the west in an
hour you got the the hills just 20
minutes north of you the beautiful
valley that it's incredible city oh yeah
they called it the city of the angels
for a reason yeah actually it's it says
los angeles has a really weird long name
over here yeah
yeah it's it's like super long it's like
the river of the women
who don't know
something like really long are you
saying that yeah i'm looking it up now
yeah we look at california man and uh
they say california is our future the
california is five years ahead of the
rest of the country no so here's what i
think i think california is going to be
a wonderful place to live in about 20
years and then texas is going to be the
problem yeah i agree
that's why people people were telling us
like you should go to austin i was like
no way oh so i i call i call it the and
i i did this once and i think it was
like
occupied democrats or blue virginia or
someone got like fears like i can't
believe you called us locust it says
well it's it's the locust theory the
locusts have no idea that they're the
ones eating all the crops they're just
wondering why all the prosperity's gone
and then they go somewhere else to find
more crops i'm like okay so no i'm not
comparing you to people to locus i'm
saying that it's this idea that someone
will come in and see all this prosperity
you know use it then destroy it and then
when they move they don't realize that
okay you're taking the policies that
created the destruction with you
maybe don't do that this time yeah yeah
i'm not calling people locusts i'm
calling them a virus
[Music]
i think this is the mindset of the world
economic forum is that people are
destroying with recklessly without
reproducing the environment so they were
like okay that's a big problem yeah they
look they look at people like a fire
like animals yeah yeah just consuming
carbon and expanding the growth and just
burning things down whatever you think
it's fascinating they never want to take
a look at the fact i can't remember who
it was that had the bet but it was with
that um oh gosh it was with
one of these one of these guys that was
predicting in the 70s that we would be
engaged in a series of world famines and
like all of our natural resources would
be paul uh
earl wreck
good guess though good guess
if you're talking about a guy that makes
crappy predictions paul krugman would
have been a really really good pick but
paul erwick and so this other economist
came in and i think he told him he's
like pick five natural resources and
i'll bet that in 20 years they're all
cheaper than they are today yep yeah and
and early engaged in the bed and lost
because it's this idea that no human
beings have this amazing capacity to
adapt if they're not being controlled by
oh i don't know an authoritarian central
government that's trying to control
their lives or treating them like
they're a virus but how about we make
that bet now
do you think things will be getting
cheaper and i would i would say from
this point forward singapore
yeah yeah i think i think we're we're
we're in for a world of hurt
if we boot russia from swift
then everything's going to get more
expensive i got a story here i think
that russia is leaving swift i don't
think that they're going to wait to get
booted i got a story from
russia-briefing.com
russia and china to develop swift
avoiding international financial systems
what's that of course i just don't know
about the source but russia and china
have been trying to get off the dollar
for a long time
so they they've i think putin's known
you can't imagine this guy has has risen
to the level he's risen to without
planning for something like this yeah
for sure
what would be inter we were
again i was talking about my team about
this like what do we think is the worst
case scenario
and what we were talking was like okay
he takes ukraine he uses that as kind of
like a trial balloon right takes ukraine
doesn't really suffer any major
consequences for it and then you start
to look at you know incursions into
places like uzbekistan kazakhstan
tajikistan where we're talking again the
belton road initiative and now you start
to see this block this russian chinese
block where you have a massive amount of
natural resources you've solved some of
the the you know population issues that
russia is having with expansion
and then you have just these major
spheres of influence
um and then it becomes almost kind of
like a remake of the cold war on some
level now again i'm not saying this is
gonna happen but i'm saying it's not
science fiction to look at this and be
like okay yeah i can look at a map and i
can look at what he's doing and i can
look at where resources are at
and i can see where spheres of influence
would potentially gain and then where do
we go from there
um
and and to your point back when it was
the west and the soviet union you had
people coming off of world war ii you
had generations that were familiar with
sacrifice familiar with fighting that
they had a strong sense of
patriotism they had a strong sense of
moral responsibility to themselves their
family their country etc and now you're
talking about a world where
i don't think anybody believes that we
have that same sense as widespread
throughout the population
uh given some of the things that we're
you know complaining about right now
and and some of the things that people
honestly believe are really key issues
um
and so it's
it's we're to look at where the
where the power dynamics gonna be from a
cultural standpoint at that point i
think moving forward if we look back at
home and we can see what's going on
culturally
i wouldn't i don't i don't i'm not so
convinced the u.s is going to be a major
player in international conflict the
same way they they are now or i i think
it's obvious that that influence is
waning thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there